بسبب خصائصها الفريده اصبحت اندرا فصيله
دم بالعالم على الاطلاق الاغريق هم اول من
اعتقدوا بفكره الدم الذهبيه لقد زعموا ان
الهتهم تحمل دما ذهبيا اين نادرا جدا وهو
ما يتمثل اليوم في الزمره او الزمره
الذهبيه هناك 35 فصيله دم لدى البشر
والزمره الذهبيه انذرها تم اكتشافها لاول
مره عام 61 وهي تنتج بسبب طفره جينيه في
البروتين المسؤول عن تحديد فصيله الدم
وبسببها يغيب العامل الذي يحدد ما اذا
كانت الفصيله موجبه او سالبه ثلاثه
واربعون شخصا فقط في العالم يملكون هذه
الزمره يعيشون حياه طبيعيه لكن غالبا ما
يكونون عرضه للاصابه بالانيميا وما يميزها
ايضا ان صاحبها يستطيع التبرع لاي شخص
لديه انواع دم نادره لكنه بالمقابل اذا
احتاج دما لابد ان يبحث عن من يحمل فصيله
دمه الذهبيه نفسها